c'est un secteur qui réunit environ 28
mille salariés dans les yvelines
en ce début d'année 2020 la fédération
française du bâtiment a dressé le bilan
dans notre département fin 2019 un
ralentissement de l'activité s'est fait
ressentir
si en 2020 le territoire accueille de
nombreux chantiers comme open sky à
plaisir l année s'annonce assez
compliquée avec les élections
municipales qui doit nous aurons un
petit peu c'est qu'on a grand paris qui
arrive et jeux olympiques qui va donner
beaucoup de travail aux majeurs c'est
d'abord les majeures mais quand il ya
une grosse part du gâteau il ya des
miettes et nous les miettes et liseron
autres et bien sûr il me faut savoir les
saisir à des jeux peu au passage
autre problématique la mauvaise image
dont pâtit le secteur du bâtiment un
secteur qui est en pleine mutation
l'écologie a une part de plus en plus
importante dans les constructions
on est là dans un secteur d'activité dû
vivre en fait dû vivre au quotidien des
français dans un moment qui est à un
moment de grande transition des
matériaux des méthodes des façons de
travailler et je crois que le bâtiment
doit montrer sa modernité
bien qu'ils proposent des métiers de
plus en plus attractif le bâtiment
n'attire pas assez les jeunes et
pourtant les offres de recrutement ne
manquent pas le budget de la formation à
la région ile-de-france c 514 millions
d'euros
dans 22 millions consacrés aux
investissements particulièrement dans
les cfa et particulièrement dans les cfa
du btp et beaucoup de travail sur les
métiers en tension dans les 25 bassins
d'emploi en 2019 dans les yvelines le
bâtiment représentait entre 8 et 9% de
l'économie du département